today elon musk is the second richest
person
in the world boasting a net worth of 155
billion dollars 127 of which was made
just this year
now he's a maverick entrepreneur working
on making some of the hardest
technological feats possible
but of course like with any entrepreneur
elon's journey was by no means smooth
and worry-free from a variety of rocket
explosions to tesla's painful balance
sheet
elon musk and his investors have poured
unreal amounts of money
into his vision for the future but how
many billions exactly is this
[Music]
starting off in this video we'll
basically take a look at all of the
biggest financial risks musk took
throughout his career and yes i
understand that these are investments
but it's not like elon was throwing
money at the s p 500
or apple today he was throwing this
money at a plethora of startups
which statistically have a 90 chance of
failure
so for the purposes of this video we'll
classify these high-risk investments as
money that he was burning
also one more thing this video isn't
supposed to hit on the guy by any means
it's just more of a fun video taking a
look at the ups and downs
of his career with that being said just
like most people around the world
elon's first financial liability was of
course student loans
musk started his educational journey at
queen's university in ontario canada
in 1989 after a couple of years here
musk would transfer over to university
of pennsylvania in 1992
before graduating in 1997. some of this
was covered by scholarships
considering that he spent eight years at
university the student loans were
nonetheless quite heavy
coming in at about one hundred thousand
dollars after finishing his studies
however
he didn't get a regular job and try to
pay off the loans
instead he decided to play a risky with
his first startup
zip2 at the time elon didn't have too
much money to begin with
so he didn't have to worry too much
about losing it with that being said
musk started as if two with his brother
for fifteen thousand dollars
out of which must contributed two
thousand dollars over the next couple of
years
it's understood that ziv2 would raise a
few hundred thousand dollars
however nearly all of this came from
venture capitalists
in 1999 zip2 would be sold for a solid
307 million dollars
and musk's seven percent equity stake
would net him 22 million dollars
but he wouldn't be able to keep all of
this money because of the tax man
it looks like elon only invested two
thousand dollars into the company
and even if he somehow invested tens of
thousands during its growth phase
the total investment amount is nowhere
near 22 million
so basically all of that would be
subject to long-term capital gains tax
and considering that anything over 434
thousand dollars is subject to the
highest rate of 20 percent
elon likely gave around 4.4 million
dollars to uncle sam
leaving him with 17.6 million this would
have been a good time to sit back
and relax but musk would instantly turn
around and invest 10 of those millions
into x.com
or what would later become paypal it's
not clear whether he invested more into
the company
as needed so we'll just say that he
didn't
as his future endeavors far outweigh
this investment anyways
paypal would eventually be sold to ebay
for 1.5 billion dollars in 2002
from which elon would receive between
165 and 175 million
or about 170 million considering that he
put 10 million dollars into the business
160 million of these dollars would be
subject to capital gains tax
which comes out to 32 million dollars
pulling his earnings down to 128 million
combining this with the 10 million he
put in and the 7.6 million that we
assumed he kept on the sidelines from
the zip2 acquisition
elon's net worth should have been about
145.6 million
so before elon embarked on his journeys
with spacex and tesla
he risked a total of 10.102 million
dollars
which left him with upwards of 150
million dollars
moving on elon would turn around and
drop 100 million dollars
into spacex in 2002 and then right after
he would pour 6.3 million into tesla in
2004.
these couple of years would be some of
the roughest in elon's life
as he would continue to fund these money
losing endeavors year
after year after year musk would later
reveal that by the end of 2008
he was out of money and if it wasn't for
the successful launch of the falcon 1
rocket and the subsequent contract from
nasa
it's quite possible that spacex would
have shut down
fortunately things would work out and
elon would be able to dig himself out of
that hole
but in the process he did apparently
risk it all
when elon says that he had no money left
in 2008
i'm going to assume that he means in
relation to the money he started with
in other words it's not like he had a
total of 100 bucks in his checking
account
rather he likely burned through 95 to 98
of the money he started with
and things were looking bleak if we say
that he burned through 95
of his initial capital elon would
roughly be left with 7.28 million
and he had burned through 138.32 million
now you may be thinking that 7.28
million
is quite a sum of money and it is
but 7.28 million doesn't stretch very
far in the ev
and rocket industries so from that
perspective he was broke
adding this 138.32 million to the 10.102
million he risked before spacex and
tesla by 2009
elon musk had risked a total of about
150 million
after this point elon didn't really
invest any money into spacex or tesla
as he didn't have any money left though
his net worth grew substantially over
the next several years
his entire net worth was tied up with
these two companies
so if he wanted to invest more into
either of these companies
he would have to liquidate some of his
position which would of course be
counterproductive
however he did have some side endeavors
that he would fund
for instance he threw 10 million dollars
at solarcity in 2006.
similarly it looks like he invested tens
of millions into deep mind
though we don't know the exact amount we
do know that he made a significant
contribution to setting up their one
billion dollar research lab
so likely to tens of millions if not a
hundred million
and what about the boring company and
neurolink
we know that musk has poured 100 million
dollars into neurolink
and will likely continue to invest
hundreds of millions into the company
likewise in 2017 alone the boring
company raised
113 million dollars out of which 90
or about 100 million came from musk just
adding
up the investments into those four
companies we get another 250 million
pushing musk's total financial risk to
400 million
and let's not forget that's just known
investments into those companies
elon musk has likely invested even more
into not just those companies
but also other companies that we aren't
even aware of
so i think we can safely add another 100
million onto that figure
and call it 500 million the real figure
is likely even higher in the several
hundred million dollar range
if not low billions but we'll keep it at
500 million to be conservative
there is one more thing to consider
though that's just how much of his own
money that he has risked
as investors have flooded into tesla and
spacex
a lot of their money has burned too in
the natural process of trial and error
we're not too sure about the financials
of musk's low-key companies
so for this estimate we'll just stick to
tesla and spacex
starting with spacex we don't know
anything about their balance sheets
as they are private company but we can
take a look at their rocket explosions
as well as the cancelled projects as for
rocket explosions
we won't be including explosions during
development as those are to be expected
and as long as development wasn't
cancelled we won't consider the money to
be burned
throughout spacex's history they've
actually only had five rocket explosions
total
with three of them being the first three
launches considering that the first
three were basically funded by musk
we'll focus on the last two both of the
failures in 2015
and 2016 were with the falcon 9 rocket
and spacex has revealed that falcon 9
launches cost them about 28 million
dollars each
thus adding up to 56 million dollars in
losses aside from this
we also have the loss of the payloads
themselves the first explosion
was during a routine space station
resupply mission from nasa
so nothing too expensive was destroyed
the second explosion however
did destroy the mo6 communication
satellite which cost a steep
195 million dollars adding that to the
cost of the rocket explosions themselves
we have a total of 250 million dollars
burned from rocket explosions
moving on to cancelled spacex projects
there are a few projects that spacex
abandoned like spaceport america
but they only invested a few million
into such projects in the first place
so nothing really major thus will say
that such failed projects
as well as other miscellaneous failures
come out to another 50 million
pushing up total investor money burn to
300 million
taking a look at tesla on the other hand
this is where the bulk of the losses
come in
as tesla was burning through hundreds of
millions of dollars per year for several
years
since going public tesla has net
quarterly losses as small as 50 million
dollars
and as large as 2.72 billion dollars if
we add up all the net losses since going
public
we get a massive loss of 26.38
billion dollars finally adding
everything up
we get a total of 27.18 billion dollars
so no doubt quite a bit of money on the
bright side though
tesla is worth over 600 billion today
and spacex was estimated to be valued at
46 billion dollars
in august so it looks like the massive
risks did pay off
but nonetheless i'm sure it didn't feel
too good when he was hundreds of
millions of dollars underwater
several times throughout his life what
do you guys think about elon's rocky
journey
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are glad that elon went on
this journey
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you